alors dégradation des océans il y a tant
de choses à dire puisque tellement de
cause qui sont en jeu quels sont les
principales menaces qui auquel font face
aux océans toute la semaine on va se
pencher sur ces menaces-là aujourd'hui
on parlait du plastique à Lisbonne
demain on va parler de surpêche on parle
d'acidification des océans
d'augmentation du niveau de la mer avec
lesrosions côtières le manque d'oxygène
dans les océans puis l'impact que ça
peut avoir sur toute la vie marine mais
aussi derrière marine protégée de
solutions de comment on peut protéger
tout ça puis des lois qui sont un peu
inefficaces à l'heure actuelle au niveau
global pour pouvoir faire du
développement durable puis assurer la
pérennité de la santé de ses océans là
pour les générations futures on sait pas
par où prendre le problème en fait si on
prend la question du plastique ça c'est
un des aspects les plus médiatisés bien
sûr je sais pas si c'est la menace la
plus la plus importante mais mais
qu'est-ce qu'on fait là ça va tripler
dans les prochaines années du temps oui
bah en fait avec le plastique
présentement je déverse l'équivalent
d'un camion à ordure chaque minute en
plastique dans les océans donc c'est
majeur et puis malgré toutes les efforts
qui sont faits pour faire des nettoyages
énormément d'efforts qui sont faits chez
nous au Canada pour essayer de contrer
un peu cette pollution plastique là le
problème c'est qu'on en est mis encore
beaucoup et tout le plastique qu'on a
produit depuis l'invention de cette
matière là existe encore parce que ça se
dégrade très très lentement sinon pas du
tout donc la quantité de plastique qui
rentre dans nos océans et majeurs sans
impact évidemment tous les animaux
marins mais ça finit par nous revenir un
peu en plein visage parce que c'est des
poissons qu'on mange qui sont remplis de
plastique maintenant les dernières
études montrent que du plastique des
microplastiques il y en a dans la bière
dans le sel de mer dans l'eau dans l'eau
du robinet dans l'eau des en bouteilles
il y en a dans les moules il y en a dans
les huîtres dans nos poissons et fruits
de mer donc c'est ces fautes pensées que
c'est juste le problème de la pauvre
petite tortue qui ingérait un sac de
plastique ça devient aussi un problème
de santé humaine comme bien des toujours
océanique parce que les océans assurent
notre santé puis notre pérennité en tant
qu'humain aussi notre espèce mais il y a
ces écosystèmes-là en soi qui sont
éminemment complexes quels sont les
principaux impacts de cette dégradation
tel qu'on les observe en ce moment
l'état de santé des écosystèmes
au sens large et mise à et mise à mal
présentement par l'état de santé des
océans et puis ces écosystèmes-là on en
dépend pour plusieurs produits et
services donc que ce soit les protéines
on a environ 15% de toutes les protéines
qui sont consommées sur terre qui
viennent de la mer c'est vrai pour le
tourisme aussi c'est des milliards de
dollars chaque année qui sont associés à
des écosystèmes marins en santé via le
tourisme c'est vrai pour le rôle qu'ils
ont dans le ralentissement de des
changements climatiques avec leur
capacité de capter une partie de nos gaz
à effet de serre donc la santé des
océans c'est la santé humaine en même
temps donc étroitement lié et quand on
parle des changements climatiques on
parle d'urgence climatique là vous venez
d'évoquer un tas d'exemple qui nous
renvoie des pratiques bien enracinées
dans nos sociétés à l'échelle collective
individuelle est-ce qui est encore temps
pour inverser la tendance renverser la
vague comme le disait monsieur goutterez
dans un extrait précédent il est encore
temps puis dans l'urgence qui a
d'intéressant c'est qu'on n'a pas le
luxe de ce passé du savoir de personnes
ce qui est discuté présentement au
sommet de Lisbonne cette semaine c'est
aussi ses partenariats et cette
collaboration là à l'international en
utilisant le savoir oui des
scientifiques mais le savoir local aussi
des communautés côtières qui vivent dans
cet océan là ou de cet océan là et puis
je pense que dans un état d'urgence que
ce soit climatique ou dans un état
d'urgence de santé d'un écosystème dont
on dépend mais on n'a pas le luxe de se
passer des connaissances de personnes
puis on le sent vraiment les bas dans ce
moment cette volonté là de travailler
ensemble pour trouver les meilleures
solutions possibles et tout par de la
volonté on le sait bien parlons de la
situation du Canada comme telle qui est
bordée par trois océans et où est-ce
qu'on constitue dans tout ce vaste
portrait et où en sont nos efforts
justement pour inverser cette tendance
mais je vous dirais qu'au Canada on n'a
pas le luxe de se dire que on est isolé
ou protégé sous une cloche de verre les
grands enjeux océaniques auxquels on
fait face à l'échelle globale ce sont
les mêmes au Canada que ce soit
l'acidification des océans le manque
d'oxygène la pollution plastique tout ce
qui est discuté cette semaine si on le
ramène à une plus petite échelle à
l'échelle de notre pays ce sont les
mêmes enjeux il y a une volonté le
Canada et et de la délégation de des
vins quelques nations qui sont
présentement Lisbonne pour discuter de
solution on a des solutions pour le
plastique on a des solutions pour
essayer de freiner le changement
climatique et l'impact que ça peut avoir
c'est d'autant plus important chez nous
parce qu'on a l'article et le changement
climatique se fait ressentir trois fois
plus rapidement dans l'article canadien
que n'importe où ailleurs sur la planète
donc des océans qui sont fragiles on a
des océans qui sont des ressources aussi
au niveau des pêcheries donc la volonté
est là puis l'importance aussi de les
protéger ses océans là et c'est crucial
et ce qui est crucial c'est l'effort de
sensibilisation qui doit être déployée
pour que la population cesse bien
l'urgence la situation dans quelle
mesure des rencontres comme celle-là et
ce qu'elles peuvent entraîner peuvent
contribuer justement atteindre cet
objectif-là que les gens comprennent
qu'on peut plus prendre les océans pour
acquis encore une fois pour citer
Antonio guteres on a longtemps pris les
océans pour acquis puis oui ce genre de
conférence là sert à se rappeler de
l'importance de l'océan pour la santé
humaine mais au-delà de ça il faut
qu'après cette réunion là qui dure une
semaine ben on revienne chez nous avec
une réelle volonté de changer les choses
puis de faire une différence là où ça
devient compliqué c'est que les enjeux
sont tellement gros que souvent c'est
facile de se sentir impuissant devant
l'ampleur de de ces enjeux de ces défis
là donc une nouvelle façon d'aborder
d'aborder les problèmes présentement qui
est de passer par l'inspiration puis
l'optimisme en prenant pour exemple les
endroits où ils ont réussi à faire des
potes géants pour la protection des
océans puis en s'inspirant de ça pour
ramener un peu les mêmes méthodes chez
nous c'est vrai entre autres au niveau
des arts marines protégées en Australie
c'est pionniers dans la mise en place
d'air marine protégée chez nous au
Canada on a encore du travail à faire
mais j'ose espérer que d'ici 2030
l'objectif est d'avoir 30% d'air marine
protégée partout sur la planète notre
pays fait partie des signataires de cet
objectif-là donc il faut s'inspirer des
endroits où ça fonctionne puis essayer
de faire la même chose au lieu d'avoir
peur de ces enjeux-là qui sont énormes
exactement pour ne pas sombrer dans le
cynisme et dans le désespoir le
fatalisme et tout le reste on s'être on
s'accroche assez à ces initiatives là
l'île Mauricette toujours très
éclairante nous entendre nous parler des
océans et de leur état de santé merci
beaucoup au plaisir bonne soirée